the partial government shutdown is
beginning its 26th day with no
negotiations planned to end it a new
White House analysis shows the deadlock
is hurting u.s. economic growth at twice
the rate previously estimated part of
the reason less spending by the 800,000
federal workers who are not being paid
the US Coast Guard commandant tweeted a
statement saying this this marks the
first time in our nation's history that
service members in a u.s. armed force
have not been paid during a lapse in
appropriations so unfortunate and this
morning the administration is recalling
some 50,000 federal employees to work
without pay
they include flight safety workers and
food inspectors as well as nearly 60
percent of Internal Revenue Service
staff that's nearly 46,000 IRS employees
there needed to handle tax returns and
refunds Carter Evans spoke with one IRS
worker in Ogden Utah the city that has
the highest concentration of federal
workers in the West now he found that
the shutdowns impact goes far beyond the
furloughed employees who live there
Carter were seeing the ripple effects
good morning good morning behind me the
city proudly displays its slogan that it
pays to live in Ogden well that's pretty
ironic now considering this shutdown is
causing a lot of economic damage here
and not just for the some 5,000 federal
workers who call Ogden home sandwiched
between federal buildings normally
bustling businesses like Ana Davidson's
restaurant are now practically empty
every week that it goes on longer it
gets slower and it's just disheartening
90% of downtown relies on the federal
workers that are down here for breakfast
and lunch business is down by half
forcing her to dig into savings to pay
her employees furloughed IRS employee
Emily Roush has gone from dining
downtown to delivering meals for
doordash driving a car with a broken
heater and taking home a quarter of her
normal salary that's not gonna pay all
the bills but at least it's gonna buy us
groceries and put gas in our vehicles so
whatever it takes whatever it takes yeah
with so many not getting a paycheck at
all I
in Mayor Mike Caldwell says the local
economy is struggling people that would
typically come down here and go to
movies and take their families out or
finding ways they can really cut their
expenses Ogden might have to do that too
declining sales leads to a loss of tax
revenue which could mean cutbacks for
this city of nearly 90,000 it could be
in the millions of dollars which would
be devastating for a community our size
so it's a big big deal a big deal with
no end in sight the president says he's
holding out for funding for his proposed
border wall and predicted the shutdown
could last for months I'm hoping they
come to an agreement and we just get
back to work later today some 300 IRS
workers here in Ogden will start getting
calls to come back to work but they're
still not going to be paid Emily tells
us if she gets the call to come back to
work she's still gonna have to keep her
second job because she's got to keep
some sort of money coming in Gayle boy
Carter thank you very much